You know what I hate?
I am Daenerys Stormborn.
The unburnt mother of dragons,
breaker of chains.
Any character you love to watch on this show
and I..
(sharp inhale)
No!
NO!
Who could have seen this coming...
NOOOOOOOOOO!!!!
Even more than that,
I hate when someone says,
"Hey, I wanted to tell you...
nevermind."
What?
Oh nevermind, it's nothing.
It's not nothing!
You can't just start to tell me something
and then change your mind
because that's all I can think about!
But it always ends up being like this:
No, seriously, tell me.
No, seriously, it's nothing.
So then tell me.
You have to tell me because now I need to know, okay?
Because the mystery part of it is killing me.
Whoa, okay,
I was just gonna say that we should do laundry today,
but then I remember that we did it yesterday.
It's always nothing!
When has someone ever said, "oh, never mind."
and it's turned out to be really important?
Never.
Yet I persist as if my life depends on it.
Never mind.
Dude, just tell me.
Well...
Out with it already.
I think it's kinda too late.
Dude, you know every time you say "oh
nevermind" it's all I can think about,
So freaking tell--
(gunshot)
Or, like whatever they say is going to be some giant secret.
Oh, nevermind.
What is it?
(sighs) Okay, um,
I'm CIA, FBI, NSA, CDC.
Quadruple agent 0.
And we want to recruit you.
All of us.
(sighs)
I knew it.
I'm so glad I insisted you tell me.
Oh my god, I know right?
I'm like, super excited to work together.
Supes excite.
But it could backfire on me.
I mean, how many times has this happened?
Nevermind.
No, what was it? Tell me.
I murdered someone.
(dramatic music)
Oh, man..
why'd you tell me that?
You insisted.
Yeah, but you could have gotten through
the whole part of the conversation
where it's like, "Oh, nothing, don't worry about it"
maybe I would have given up.
Yeah, but...
no one ever gives up.
You know? So I just felt like I would save you the time
and just come out with it already.
Well, that's nice.
I do appreciate you thinking about my time.
Oh, one second, I just have to make a quick call.
(cell phone beeps)
Hi,
yeah, my friend's a murderer.
(softly) Sorry...
(softly) It's okay...
Yeah, I know, come get her..
What about you?
When someone says, "Oh, nevermind"
are you able to just like let it go and drop your fucks,
or are you like me,
and paranoid,
and you have to know what they were gonna say?
Do I overreact?
(crying)
NO!!!! THAT WAS MY FAVORITE CHARACTER TO WATCH!!
NOOOOOOOOOOOOO
I'm Anna Akana.
Stay awesome, Gotham.
I'd like to say thank you to Audible
for sponsoring today's kingdom.
Audible is the leading provider of audiobooks
with over 180,000 titles to choose from,
across all types of literature.
I love listening to audiobooks when I'm conquering the world..
Currently, I'm listening to Game of
Thrones: A Song of Fire and Ice,
because there's much to learn about the iron throne.
Audible is currently offering a free 30
day trial for you to try out their service.
Go to audible.com/anna to download a free title,
and start listening today.
That's audible.com/anna.
Dracarys.